[Music]
[Music]
do you understand English
absolutely mapa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening please welcome Academy
governor and vice president Larry
karaszewski Wow great crowd thank you
all very much for coming I'm very
excited to be here tonight representing
the Academy's international feature film
Executive Committee I'm co-chair that
committee along with Diane wireman from
the documentary branch right there she
has a front row aisle seat that's one of
the few perks you get for being a
co-chair this has been an extraordinary
year and I want we want to give a
special welcome to the cast and crew
members of the five nominated
international films that are here in the
audience with us tonight thank you so
much for your work it it blew us away
[Applause]
the work was so amazing it's actually
nominated in numerous other categories
at the Oscars this year and that's very
very rare but international films are
nominated for best production design
best editing best documentary Best Actor
Best Screenplay Best Director and Best
Picture it's a it's just an
extraordinary lineup I want to talk a
little bit about how we got here because
this category works a little differently
than other Oscar categories our work in
this category really began at the
beginning of October over 90 countries
submitted films for consideration this
year and our committee basically would
meet five to seven times a week in this
theater or in our sister theater to
Linwood done in Hollywood and we watched
every film it's a long process it takes
three months but it's a total joy I mean
literally every time the lights would
come up we turn to each other and be
like oh my god it's a masterpiece it
really is it's it's the greatest Film
Festival in the world but it you know it
does take dedication so I know there's a
lot of members in the audience right now
who who put in a lot of effort in that
in that committee so if you're here can
you please stand so we we can thank you
for your dedication we could not do it
without you
once we watched all 90 films we then had
to come up with a short list in previous
years it was nine films this year we
liked the movie so much we we made it
ten films maybe next year will be full
spinal tap and get 11 but right now I
think we're happy with 10 and also for
the first time we opened up voting the
final voting for nominations to all
Academy members who saw all 10 films
that's great yes and I'd say that one of
the big reasons for that is the
Academy's international membership is
growing and growing and growing and we
felt it's very important to get their
input so that this category has you know
has global or global voice because I
think that's variables is the best
international feature film we are very
lucky that we have all five directors
actually six directors because there's a
team that direct one of the films here
tonight we're gonna do a Q&A with them
but first we're gonna show a bunch of
clips from their work so you can get a
taste of the best in international film
thank you very much for coming
you
from France Leamas Rob largely director
they do lock
telepharmacy come on boy servi it's a
very mean Oliver ready - hold on - look
kiss you fit on say kiss your face leave
up his teaching go are they cute huh
wait yes a little early so nobody like a
pile of security
Tammi libido is you push yourself
so gonna be a very sexy microchip
Hey
see bossy boiler
palapas consuela suela come on pretty
short are tricky material sarah she
compensation bill a back exit video soon
she says your name alone familiar
Shanthi emergency but how do you even
wash it on a mama what is it isn't
the officer Petrovic maquas on relevee
are coming for a sharp work on signal
promote LOC recoup Astros Dapitan vidura
s allah o allah proper grace oblem okay
skeezy passes republics are even cheaper
to Monaco need or catch a zombie on you
antabuse el Conejo BIA
from North Macedonia hadeel and
Luba stuffing off and Tamara kotovsky
hmm daya 7r Armida rather nice look at
them
if saving some time so he'll kill ya
you kept your cash cow sudden he's
dancing awesome you can do kiss Bob yeah
someday
Romilly bar get it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from Poland Corpus Christi Janka Massa
director
[Music]
Oh it'sa me worst Bogota asked upon
inertia go Azusa crystal sir he dared
not chief Lucas wedding vendors vanished
give me
she shot as much of each model phone
Yatta new president rappers from work
managers with the snare first book that
is not evidence now bottome to his - me
nobody stock regime in the Kostova
but similarly God is really among seen a
shadow watch this tacky truth like group
distance came to the Gypsy no sir
okay mom Jeremy no
okay someday someday
- Apollo
techno Proust actuary terrace
Oh goddess is bargain - people vinegar
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from South Korea
[Music]
[Music]
now you can come on coach it will also
time to the toon car
[Music]
Humberto
so now we can examine their I mean
controversial and you didn't it printed
I sell the comes ok Basu conjecture a
person de vida de música de tener una
vez mas de cacao
schibetta's una hora de unión de
tarragona Pau Gasol go Segundo
[Music]
Oxshott egos which ones do I see
[Music]
from Spain pain and glory Pedro
almodóvar director how does it not see
them winning welcome you know me
personally recommend are elevated a
patella y creo que debe gastar polish
system poco clarify yourself seminario
dimension just personal but she had to
tell tiempo para esta Molly Molly o tu
Padre
Teddy sexy can you ask him a further we
will continue to score Eastern Bhutan
this is taking me Baba should nobility
no era para poder compartir con me go
it's how you man you very much pero la
casilla tengu stupid I mean that's all
you having peaceful muddy okay you might
have either Bharati I bequeath identity
maybe had a Pokemon yet update out and
touch courses we don't know quiche East
seemed to mutual nervous you know Kelly
over to the service
only fear
knocking over a silly ghost any new no
ICS pretty something too
[Music]
you
the fellows implemented Boozer kansui
siento mucho perturbation Antonio
[Music]
[Music]
mr. nature is very pretty
yo te ayudo este mundo me - we'll be the
personal Talent
is this me when you go to mothers
with him your name was up world to you
you mind you better get has a feeling
there's gonna this
don't you
[Music]
don't look with a completely promise
what a stunning group of motion pictures
I just want to I almost want to go watch
all five of them again there was a big
change in this category this year we
actually changed the name of the
category up until now it's always been
best foreign language film and this year
we changed it to best international
feature film it's something that we
talked about for many many years and it
really it really came to a head because
of Afonso scre owns a magnificent joke
on stage of the Oscars this year he
talked about how much he loved growing
up watching foreign films foreign films
like jaws and Citizen Kane and it's a
great joke it's a great joke because it
touched on something that was true that
cinema is a universal language and we
just watched five clips there is nothing
foreign about any of these movies they
all deal with the universal themes of
community and have so much empathy for
the human condition it's they took me
seriously when I said they want to watch
them all right there we go it is my
honor to bring to the stage the
directors behind these five magnificent
films from France the director of Lina's
Rob largely
hello sir good to see you from North
Macedonia the directors of honey land Lu
Bo Stefan off and tomorrow kukuczka
the very first documentary ever
nominated for Best International feature
hello though congratulations from Poland
the director of Corpus Christi Janka
Massa from South Korea the director of
parasite bong joon-ho welcome and from
Spain the director of pain and glory
Pedro almodóvar
[Applause]
[Music]
before you guys came out I actually
mentioned that there's a lot of members
of your cast and and and crews out here
in the audience and I'm wondering if you
guys would like to go down the row and
actually single out any members of your
team that are out there large who from
your team is out there in the audience
you know Ilana did the predictor to Fick
I stopped by a little comedian Jay
Brady's on gala sorry I stand up whoa
whoa honey LAN do you have anyone out
there everybody
everybody all right please everybody
find Oscar here the producer and editor
hey Mead out in summer Yuma
cinematographers
[Music]
and our dearest guest tonight Rana eight
she's the sound designer and we haven't
seen her since December 1 and we can't
wait to see you Jana is there anyone out
there from your film a lot of plenty of
them first of all my producers let's
check both the kinetic eating bottom
main character main actor butters
B'Elanna
and my other actors at least resemble
antemer Gentek are here and my my teepee
obviously pure so much in skis here my
elder some extra chairs keys here and
somebody who started at all the
scriptwriter punk team here quite many
our great editor young Jim mo is here
and production designer
Hajin and by great co-writer on gene one
is there also and our wonderful producer
coxinha is there and also my friend
[Applause]
and also helping us in everything
Barba rapido which is there assists me
in fantastic company a very good
photographer is like my he's very tall
then you know if you have a problem of
chin of double chin then the I mean
under his camera you never have double
chin which is you know kind of advantage
all right great let's do this some of
you've been out promoting these movies
for since the Khan Film Festival even
Sundance so this is like this might be
your last QA if you can believe it
unless you schedule a couple before
Sunday my I'm trying gonna try to ask
questions that all of you can answer
that's a little difficult sometimes but
my first one is really why now why was
this movie important for you to make at
this time either in your life or
politically or what was what was you
know why was this the movie you had to
make right now and well it's to start
with let's start with honey land this
what I mean obviously you guys are you
guys are actually taking on one of the
great issues of our time sustainability
but so why was this movie something you
had to make why now I think this film as
we think how we speak as among each
other obviously that this film would be
always important to make not just now
because it's something that we all carry
inside of ourselves this human side that
maybe today is the most forgotten what
what a teacher the main character our
film is reminding everyone is of
something that it's very likely that
very soon will be forgotten of respect
towards everything around us
first we didn't plan to be here when we
started handling but we think that we
succeed to find to find the probably the
most clear way to do to to show this
woman's message which is so important in
this terrible times sharing and hearing
sense of sustainability and probably
this film is recognized because young
can you tell us about why you why you'd
wanted to make this movie right now
maybe tell us a little about the origin
of the project yeah well this story
Corpus Christi was inspired by real
events so it happened in 2011 the main
event of a man pretending to be a prison
poem for four months during Corpus
Christi holiday and it's basically it
started with this story it's inspired so
we a lot of elements were added to the
original story by the scriptwriter
matiush Pat savage but it came like it
was sent to me by the producer and I
basically was sent a lot of different
scripts and resonated with me so much
because I felt like this story tells
something very significant about
fractured communities and I feel like we
given that we live in a time in which
communities become pretty polarized we
tend to be needing somebody who make us
come all together and sit by the one
table and talk so this film is about it
and I felt it's important to tell this
story and bong why us is actually
returned to a smaller filmmaking for you
you were coming off of snorts no piercer
and and okay uh they were sort of like
some of our English language films big
action kind of movies this is a much
more
film you chose to go back to your roots
Sasha who parasites at home ideal told
no attention and they Ocana Sargon your
child who by July was dead so actually
it was 2014 when I was working on the
post-production at the snowpiercer that
I came up with this idea for the
parasite Segundo Chatham open-book your
table and couldn't you ji-sun and the
parasite to talk research is it okay
this time to change applicaton go go
can I go in Cosmo deny intelligent
answer okay
they got Kotaku boat Otto : shitty as
hell get the McCrone gonna tell
so actually snowpiercer was also about
class disparity and naturally parasite
is also dealing about that same subject
and it wasn't like the teen came to me
because I were obviously living in the
society and dealing with this class
struggle so can they I can touch you but
interrogate come torture pattern go to
Vegas on taking anywhere so it's not
like I selected it but I've said I've
been cursed to do this I have no choice
that's why now you had no choice Pedro
what this feels like a very personal
phone for you it yep you know I really
don't know why I write one a story and
not other stories so when I start I mean
I remember when I start how was I was I
have a surgery and when I was recovering
and then I used to I used to go today I
mean the swimming pool and I am and I
submerged myself every day it was the
more beautiful moment of the day because
because of the lack of gravity all the
mass there is no there is no pain there
is no disappear I mean all the weight
disappear and after doing that you in
like a month
I always am taking notes not I don't
have any kind of journal but I take
notes about and because it was the more
intimate moment of of the day are also
the more pleasurable and I took some
notes of that M being alone I mean with
my mind and with my memories and
immediately I wrote I mean the water of
the swimming pool just driving me to
another kind of current and that it was
the river of my my childhood and then I
I keep on writing the yes the sequence
where my my mother and with the
neighbors go to the river and it was a
festivity for me I remember I was just
just a kid and it was really I mean for
me it was like life also the I mean
something very very happy even they were
working and it was hard but full of joy
and also they used to sing and when I
when I just robbed the third sequence
and then I discovered that I was talking
about myself and that I was just the
first reference for the main character
they Antonio Banderas character and you
know then then I have I because many
people ask me why you do gujrat his
script now about yourself and I don't
know I don't know I I mean and all the
other question is did you need I mean
did you feel the necessity of doing it
oh I don't know I know I I just you know
you start writing and in my case I mean
the writing in this case is the cross if
accordion tarawa the current the current
like the current of water just drives me
to another sequence and another sequence
and it was yesterday that the main idea
of the movie yes how these men combined
I mean his solitude in this moment with
all the memories of his boyhood and when
he was a young adult
on the contemporary time so I mean they
only in the middle of that then I asked
myself I really want
I mean I'm prepared to expose myself
like that I mean I should think that
perhaps during a year I will be in
Hollywood and everybody is going to ask
me about why I write this in this
precise moment of my life and even
Dharam I don't know but I I did I did
and I'm very happy and you know it was
not a kind of therapy I never write yes
it has to be holistic with myself almost
the opposite they are perceived but you
know this is how I start on I'm trapped
and now I'm here with you we join with
all of us with you with you with you
talking about our movies what's funny is
upstairs you actually mentioned the fact
that you said that when you started
working on it you you were really you
really felt like you why would anyone
care you were like sir you're almost me
it was so personal to you that you were
sort of questioning whether like you
know it's just going to be interesting
for other people is that when you're
putting it together
yep sit realmente quantum buffet I
scribble pensee assumed cabrito mio
perro creo que esto sólo Nevada I wanna
wear the me Nadia the segadores and
Madrid because it had mis amigos pero
hace career TV look it's true when I
started writing I thought you know this
is me just being sort of stubborn and
wanting to write this story that's not
going to be interesting to anybody other
than a few of my friends in Madrid but I
continued anyway and I kept writing the
story so it was a big surprise that the
movie interests many people but it's
always a kind of miracle when that
happens because you cannot plan it you
cannot you know Planeta kate this so
that I was I was sure that it was just
for a small community living in Madrid
and lodge your film feels like an alarm
bell like torn from today's headlines
and in the streets
why do you think this movie was
important to you to make right now but
some people want to date me know it a
diminutive transmission comes on the
different projects you don't even happy
Yamashita important determinate the
condition video this is a bit all scream
alloys monel triple a parolees
entrepreneur and this experiment on
promising and finish apart on about one
team when you screw because aperture
security yeah well it was it was really
a worse dealing with minorities and
talking about minorities but it was
mostly we realized screening it from
countries to countries that i was
talking about people from all around the
world it was about talking about people
misery and people's life conditions and
finding a way for people to express
themselves no initiative et cetera et
cetera film cetera to our opponent on a
faded cop watching second sister a
familiar policy economic activity Donna
Katya C difficile veritable policy
diffuser video internet
citizen okay delicious que la policía
policía still upon a house cat
apologetic on Danny
Knox a tell upon the powder don't know
few millimeter Archimedes
yes I I did find my first camera when I
was 17 so I started shooting everything
at sea and so I started doing also what
we call cup watching and some people
some of our neighbors were jealous of a
police blunder once and so from that
time that police blender which I managed
to shoot because some neighbors called
me we managed to women age to trigger
some sort of enquiry but the police of
police in France and for the first time
cops officers were suspended because
because of this witnessing tada Amoy
don't contradict our message competence
important vitamin C is extracted Allah
we should absolutely Mochrie president
Larry public Francisville affinage
Audrina will feel relatability boundary
female on Monday as a minister the
Toyota soda shop
proceed immediately condition video the
cigar TV audio feed atrocious caliber
say yes for me the the message of the
movie is really really important it's a
movie that must be seen it's a it's a
call of action so it was really really
important for for me and for us that the
French president would see it and he did
see it and was quite touched by it and
asked his ministers to work on the
situation and find solutions and now
being at the Oscars today this year is
is paramount
next question yon you can start with
this each one of your films has an
extraordinary look but they're so all so
different
can you talk about your your visual
plans for for your film I mean if your
film particularly it's almost it starts
very dissatisfied with your pure so much
in ski to to use lock off camera sort of
to contain this the feeling of the main
character basically he is released from
a juvenile detention center he's 21 in
the film so the only thing he knows
getting into life basically adult life
so to speak as the prison and so we
decided that maybe the the camera when
it's static it will translate into the
film as something which basically limits
with the borders with the frames the
walls of the frame it's sort of like the
prison for the main character so that
was our first theoretical approach to it
we decided to destroy it sort of with
with two shots one which is the opening
held handheld camera shot and the last
first one and the last one first scene
and the last scene of the film our
handheld so that was one element the
second element was colours when we it
was pure idea he you know he comes he's
great he comes from he's a natural
talent he comes from this film makers
family his father and grandfather were
Cinematographers as well so for him it
was naturals it's like the moment he
read the script he said I remember he
said well let's make this look like if
it's a dawn for the main character
because he enters the life and his life
and he doesn't know what's going to what
what is going to happen so the moment
when he enters a life it's dawn the
moment he realized that he has the
Epiphany moment and the calling he feels
the calling then the Sun comes into the
frame so these two elements basically in
the play between them was the defining
factor of Corpus Christi um can you talk
about your visual approach you you
actually do very elaborate storyboards
correct well Connie jomo run obsequious
a storyboard romanika didn't a step to
try catch it again more recent including
will Cody Meszaros it's a habit of mine
because I want to get rid of my anxiety
and actually my crew they also
appreciate the storyboards I feel like
there's we're on the same boat with the
storyboards I know very well there is
great master filmmakers who never draw
the story without storyboard we can make
great movie I know but for me personal
problems I'm very very obsession also
keep drawing the every shot and actual
the final movie is not so much different
from the storyboard and a jacuz HR and I
man indeed ingenuity and Jung Jae Pyo
got you got to promise of an epoch to
get ahead and storyboard wrong ones and
they know what his tank and utterly
dingy goon who's hypothesis I say I
don't know is something that I should be
proud of or boast about because I mean
there's definitely element that I need
to be more flexible and work with the
former's actors at the sit to allow more
freedom but the fact that the storyboard
matches with the final picture I don't
I'm not so sure it's something that I
should be proud of
Oh Hitchcock did that yeah now is that
why they're the the houses were sets
because they've they were true you were
trying to match your storyboards to and
you couldn't find the exact house that
would that look like that from the
beginning we made a plan to design the
whole house from the beginning we
already know it's impossible to find out
the location we want so the problem is I
always make my own storyboard after I
took take a picture of the three
locations but in this case you're making
the litchi house and all the house says
so during that process there is no
physical existence of the set so it
makes me nervous and anxious and so what
we tried was actually we helped create
the visual effect team that they made
they provided me some very beautiful the
birch or the set over the leach house
because the computer is so that you can
work a roleplay game at Endicott like
achieve an immense oh okay such a mega
kochenko Gangaram Biddy and glitter data
check our scene and kraan Bajoran
settlement Rosa
the Google patent racist or voter
mondongo so an integer so in a story
about a moment ago Tonya I had this
program in my computer and I would
actually go into this program and walk
around like just as I was in there and
try out the angles to make sure that I
was getting what I wanted
it was based on that that I drew and
came up with the design the storyboard
he got what he got requiring he had a
leading researcher in charge of some
capture would've enjoyed going back to
what I mentioned earlier I don't know
it's something that I should post about
that the storyboard matches to find a
picture but um is my obsession that I
have Pedro can you talk about your
visual approach you worked with your
longtime sumit ography you've made many
films with this with the cinematographer
correct excuse me yeah I work again with
Jose Luis al Qaeda which is one of the
best DPS in Spain I mean I remember you
for example he was the DP of this L sure
the south from big torrid affair
one of the biggest Spanish masterpieces
and and you know I mean they didn't
really I thinking about this movie pain
and glory
I didn't talk so much with him this is
the advantage of having worked together
during many many movies and he knows
very well about my taste about what kind
of colors I want and I like and and also
you know curiously he's one of the VP's
that he's taking care of I mean taking
care of the faces of the actors that and
he tried to make them the more beautiful
possible because he has that idea that
they the actors should be I mean and so
I mean made a big big the light was a
killer fear Illumina total said pero
después leave a week
a specific comment a la cara de los
doctores que muchos opera doors que no
lo hacen Kenan
so he's the kind of cinematographer who
will like the whole set but then he
takes care of also thinking about how
he's gonna light the actors which is not
always a case with cinematographers
cambian literally came a alkyne
epinephrine experiencia analodjica
perfecto para career para darle call or
displace camera camera a common emotion
or amid more digital and because he's
also someone who's had a long experience
in analog cinema then he also has the
experience to be able to color the faces
and grade the film in the digital
post-production process
yo creo que el mejor modo de sac our lil
mayor parte de possibly a loss camera
digitalis SK Labrador a cannot Carla
technique Ontario and I really do think
that the way in which technicians let's
just say can take advantage of the
digital medium is by actually being
well-versed in the analog medium in the
previous medium large you come from the
world of documentary you you come from
shooting your own films and this
obviously extends to Tulane is rob their
appeals it feels like a panther curve
almost here that you're really capturing
what's what what's happening so talk
about your visual approach to
documenting I want to film a film
premiere in premiere fictions it only
Dutch Indies and the document air show
to decisions team of Kamehameha do PGD
don't depreciate is a terrific passer
llamo nom upon a fiction she said a
party circuit dr. Martin on a fiction
circuit reproach diesel - Tate eight
Tonio camera Le Bourget cancel second so
get it on
a shaman opposite opee yes this is my
this is my first fiction narrative
feature before I only shot mostly dogs I
shot about ten documentaries before
since I've been shooting movies since I
was 17 so I really wanted to bring a
very realistic documentary feel to it so
we shot most sequences all sequences and
with an NL camera cinema the first ones
in emotionality which must be Pasha no
she said oh hope instead eccentric you
know Thomas said Donna said comes within
a three-minute Mesilla since inclusive
accused of two capacity omakase Scalia
departure Bettina said to hoc a short on
Jerry Palacios Artesia victim of a
policy they don't shut up in New Year's
Eve because it's a concern my opponent
or national who Tony Dorsett memcache is
Kelly
he started editing yes I'm trying to
make to create cinema that's based on
real life so on on scenes experiences
that I that I lived so under last scene
especially this scene under stairwell
it's actually it's totally based on real
life it's a it's it's a happening
actually I completely witnessed so it
was really important for me to recreate
it and I actually happen to be in in the
stairwell of my own building example a
second super Chileans okay typically she
Thomas pies she Vicki said same
Java digital genomic kappa continuous
although the circus she never taken
second cinema
same thing with the singing of the lion
cub it's completely based on real life
it really happened one of my friends
when I was 18 did still land cub from
whose circus so honey land is such an
apt title for that film and the visual
approach of your movie that is literally
I feel like it's a movie that only
exists almost at that at Magic Hour it's
such a beautiful beautiful film can you
talk about your your your visual
approach to making this film well sure
we had about 400 pages of storyboards
and a lot of equipment we had everything
but the problem was we couldn't take it
there because there's no roads and
there's no electricity so in the end we
ended up with two dslr's and from there
was a discussion in the green room and
everybody so we'll film turn Alexis
right not really
so I know our story is very different or
cinematography sir here we should this
one on DSLRs and on icons no nobody done
this
okay all right sorry and we were using
only because the filming locations were
actually the plane and the rock where
she's keeping the honey and everything
else is is inside her cottage and and in
family's backyard so basically I don't
believe it
any other solution than our DSLRs which
sure bring us to the better result in
this it's the same kind of sabotage yes
and whoever it has it can you please
like leave or walk out and figure out
what's going on because it's really very
distracting we really apologize for this
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
inside alright we don't have such things
that occur in our and so you basically
you you you you you both split up
correct and you shot sometimes actually
it worked a lot because we were only
able to be there for a couple of days
and we had to use all the time we have
so the team of double directors and
double cinematographers worked very well
talk a little bit about the
screenwriting stage Pedro you talked a
lot about that earlier but some of the
other people happen to lots of people
have either wrote the film or co-wrote
the film
bong how important is it for you for the
for the brother screenwriting in the
structure are you you've been working on
this one for quite a long time correct
yeah so very first idea was in 2013 and
14 and during almost four years it was
in my head during when I was making this
no piercer and OCHA they keep I keep
developing it in my mind but actual
screenwriting is about four four and a
half months funny thing is until very
last moment there was no structure of
that second half of the movie all this
[Music]
almost of them already watch the movie
may is spoilers no way there is a
basement in the leach house and there is
a hidden husband in the bunker all those
things came to me in the last three
months so me and co-writer try our best
to making first half and micro writer
did many research for the real people
and then he he provides me many
wonderful details and nuances and but
anyway all those the second half of the
movie came in debated later so the
calculus actually currents on taste the
scenario Simeon you take piranha or on
underneath her wind a coup runner get a
jog in Cujo gone isn't a sophomore
Cassio jogging Brannon day yaw damper
look rich Lannister so usually when that
happens I become you become anxious
because you wouldn't have the structure
of it but this time when I was working
on it
even though I didn't have a structure
and even though I was getting into this
detail of the story I didn't feel that
anxious at all yeah I I don't know I
because I'm always anxious but it was
2017 the autumn and winter
time I was very confident and then you
know in the movie the very last part of
the movie there is a Morse code the
father and son communicate in a very
strange way a weighted Morse code it
also came to me in the very last months
of the screenwriting so it means
actually during two or three months of
actual type writing it means I didn't
know that the very last part of the
movie during that but the pure energy
analysis but I wasn't anxious I just
kept on writing very exceptional case to
me for example my previous movie called
matters from the beginning I have the
call the very last image or with all the
the ladies and matter is advancing in
the learning path it was in my mind from
the very beginning oh but the
screenwriting the parasite it was very
exceptional case I heard that you you
actually when you were young we're a
tutor for a rich family it's quite
common in South Korea quite many
university student theatre job and I
take a pooja chicoy so I was a tutor for
rich family but obviously I didn't kill
anyone
the COO or you take I had done come home
to me and I got a ticket in Karachi
bohemian-chic in the domestic trouble
ruin j-rock and dad and then story rahat
rng you need to think so I wouldn't say
that it's because of that experience
that I came up with the story it's more
or less because more about each of the
family members going and infiltrating
that sort of built up and became the
story itself but I remember very vividly
the moment when I first super lychee
house and it's the smell you talked
already a little bit about the
screenwriting process when you're
writing your script when you get to the
set how how closely do your your shoots
resemble your screenplay well I tried to
be very closed but I didn't I mean I
give me all the freedom to adapt to
everything because a certain is
something alive everything is alive in
u.s. shooting so even I mean I think
that I don't start the people until I
have a very irony script then with the
rehearsals with the actors I change
almost every day and sometimes even that
the script is very tight and very like
iron I mean for example in pain and
glory
there is three sequences that casually
by casual it was they were screaming
when we reopen we came that I wrote then
in the last minute just the night before
you know sometimes even if you are very
conscious about what you are doing
sometimes you need a lot at least in my
case you need to be shooting to discover
that there is there is necessary to do
something else and then when I when I
start they work in the older part
the old mother I was so fascinated by
the arteries probably the Serrano at
also that part it also was very close to
my life when when she asked Antonio if
she if he remember how she wanted to be
pressed when he will be there all that
part I was very shocked about because
about the arteries enough also because
it was something that happens in my life
and then then I I mean that night I
wrote the three sequences when when they
are at the corridor when the mother said
in Spanish for me oh gosh you don't
wanna hop on me I mean how do you say
that in this beginning dear son you have
not been a good son to me
I'm the rest and when they go because of
course he's very surprised I mean
something so almost cruel
and the other sequence that I think is
it is very essential in a movie when the
mother reproached him that when when she
went a widow that he didn't take her to
Madrid to live with him and to take care
of him
that was also new and I remember I gave
them the pages viewing at the same money
so I mean I need always actors like in
this case Julieta on the antonio that
they don't mind to I mean just to
rehearse and at the same time learning
the the new sequences even they they are
very excited because you know if you can
you can work with after that I mean you
cannot change a single word but they are
just the opposite so you know in the
last minute you know they arrive these
three sequences that I think they are
very important for for the movie so I
mean in my case I I need to have the
feeling to build a very strong script
and since then I'm ready to improvise
and to adapt because I mean I know even
you know I are only
I don't only write the screen but also
sometimes I write difference is obvious
describe Italian differences of fairness
paradoxical dip and our personalities so
sometimes I even write the different
different options for one action for the
characters he is from a Ithaca Qo'noS
Camus Yvonne dormers person office
inclusive parties can operator in la
película and that allows me to sort of
to get to know the characters really
well even though some of those things
may never appear in the film
entrada he shall go Tom Bebo que una
Teaneck adapter C econ do fear lo que tú
quieras
pero no idea Jafar todo lo que they
would mother spent on your introduction
of riffing and it's because the shoot is
always so alive so you sort of have to
let it guide you in the direction it's
taking us in the direction that you want
to take it but you have to be able to
adapt and take advantage of some of that
information that it gives you I'm
curious about the structure of your
movie because you have the filmmakers
story and then you have the mother's
story the young story but then there's
actually even a third element which is
the monologue sort of the second almost
a second flashback and how when did that
become part of the process
yeah you know sometimes you know I died
I did these twice or three times I mean
the screens are the result of two or
three different stories that I wrote in
advance so I mean the best thing is just
for me to write and keep it in my
computer and if I'm not completely happy
about the story so there is a moment
when that story on that set piece find
the right place in one movie for example
before pain and glory in talk to her the
the sequence the mute sequence the
silent movie there appears the shrinking
lover it was something that I have
already written before I I have a script
about a drinking lover with a whole
story but I
get an ending that I that I thought I
was enough satisfied but the idea always
I mean it was in my mind because always
I remember films like freaks or unique
or diabolical producing I mean where
they are very very very small always
drinking or the Incredible Shrinking men
they always thought about a man like
these are the decoration is I mean this
part I mean the basis of the on the
furniture always dream of doing
something like that so so that's why I
wrote this drinking lover but I didn't I
didn't get a whole theme so I put it
when I when I when I brought up to her
and then I need the protagonist the
nurse to tell one story in black and
white of a silent movie then it was
perfect because also I found a way to
explain that this nurse who is going to
commit a crime because I mean he's going
to rape a woman which is in common you
know
I mean everything that happens because I
didn't want to saw him doing that but I
need to explain the spectator that that
thing was happening in that moment so
that was then I remembered that I was
the wrinkle and it was perfect I when I
could make a giant vagina and the main
completely I mean he's very inside her
which is very obvious of about what what
what it was happening but you know it
was the result of missing two different
stories so in this and I'm going to be
brief in pain of glory there is also
three set pieces that belong to another
period that I written before like 20
years before one is them the origin the
first desire and when the kid fainted
that was studied was written before
perhaps to make a short but I never did
it so I kept it in my computer and I
also have the
monologue of addiction actually
authority at the moment when I wrote it
it was like memories of the eighties in
Madrid that was very close to that
period until a decade with this
explosion of freedom that of course I
mean drugs well including all that and
then I wrote it thinking about a girl
but I kept it I kept it I didn't do
anything with it you know I write I
wrote pain and glory that it was at the
moment that he's a director and he said
writer and and I mean I gave to the
character effrontery of my house I mean
they were the place where Antonio least
is a replica of my house the paintings
are my paintings they 42 run sometimes a
Snickers also they are mine so as high
so I was very close to the character so
it fit very well to that memories these
three things the other the third part it
was something that I wrote about about a
director and an actor so I put this all
together and it fit them very well so
sometimes I mean for me writing is like
that I mean you you know when you start
writing my Gerardo when you finished and
so is good you collect everything in the
computer you there is one moment when
you have the opportunity to you to show
it and to put it so sorry to ask the
silly question said how do you invent
the whole structure of talk to her
is it so so yeah I'm so I'm curious
about it so yeah it's such an amazing
that you ask me that your is impossible
to I mean this is Santa you now have two
or three scripts that I wrote like like
very quickly one it was women in the
rest of his breakdown and another one
these pain and glory but counting that
we have the three stories but the rest
of my filmography
talk to her I lead I lived with that
story during years a bad education it
was a result of ten years not nothing is
right in every day attendees of cooking
all about my mother also I mean I used
to have many different story
in my table and the Indian different
states of development and there is one
moment when once you know he says to me
that is is ready when they have more
than 100 pages then I start writing the
story but I usually leave surrounded
surrounded by many stories and you know
this is a problem when you as in his
years alright now that I cannot spend
ten years with you for an for an idea
that I have now this is very bad about
age and about getting order but perhaps
the best movies of my career they were a
very slow cooking on simultaneously
about many many years thank impossible
to do it directly Wow irrational wise
can you talk about your how you put
together this skip you're one of the
co-chairs of the movie and I was talking
to I think your producer earlier tonight
and he mentioned that they actually saw
like one of your shorts online and
that's sort of how the movie star
affective malfunction my survey said she
didn't owe me trash me facet complicated
multi don't Kaneda seeded the common
super famicom it has a victory project
on okinawa incorrigibly OCD mr. Alcala
Tony Abbott Rizzo sweet cotton I really
succeeded city settlement develop a
reversal America so no difficulty no
unknown Tomas a Creole cuisine re-secure
Georgians personalism it's a comedy CD
don't repay
a sinner is confirmative a
disappointment experience in ontology
only shows in Omaha July 20 plan is to
append anecdote repointed nodd ho to on
Israel comes up escape advisement Islam
because she is indeed from the beginning
my idea was to really direct a feature
length but clearly it was very difficult
I was really difficult to put together
so we had the idea was the producer to
make a short film which did really well
so so because it really well then we
went on to work on the future it still
took about three years we had I had
several ideas clearly but I felt like I
wanted to work with another screenwriter
on this so I worked with one who lives
in Belgium we did a lot of Skype
conversation and exchanged a lot of
ideas and talked a lot I had there was a
lot of ideas and memories I wanted to
share with him working on this together
how about on the set a mere film feels
very alive and naturalistic as there is
are they following
script pages or are they improving how
much improvisation is done
oppressive Akana
a scenario a CPC as a structural major
shlessinger on par with Liberty I'm a
comedian so deuteronomy's a currency
should only see children seconds of the
Carter blueprint proposition it's like
only family Chakri's a WITSEC inspector
haymann important canals in our
commercial structure a mica man in power
and political media yes initially the
the script was very precise and very
structured but working with actors I
always made sure we to give them enough
freedom especially on certain sequences
so so yeah clearly the script was quite
quite tight in structure but we worked
on some sequences where you know
slightly improvised and honey land you
know I don't know whether you actually
had obvious you had an idea that you
were doing but for me I'm more almost
fascinated by in terms of how you guys
structured the film
I mean you shot like 400 hours of movie
you this movie was really discovered in
in the in the cutting room correct when
I found out some piece of information
saying that you guys spoke no Turkish
whatsoever so when you were out there
you didn't know what anybody was talking
about you were just filming and Wow
so talk about that that's that's
mind-blowing I'm sorry I can't imagine
how disturbing the official screenplay
we had after the first rough you backed
into it but we we started thinking about
where this story will go on one of the
first shootings when we saw a teacher
taking half of the honey and returning
half to the bees we knew immediately
this is the thing we want to
and we started we spend we spend the
next six months just with her and trying
to to get as much possible up from this
message from how she lives her life and
after the six months this family showed
up and the screenplay changed the mince
how do you how do you make the film not
knowing what you're saying you're
actually cutting the film and you don't
know what the what the conversations are
going back and forth you know well in
the in the shooting we knew what they
were what's the topic of their concert
[Laughter]
yes we were happy sure sure but actually
it was very very fun process to do the
editing of this film and discover a
completely new film well I do you think
we also want to say thank you to the
best creme screenplay writer in our team
which is now Siva I did just mother we
put the first the first rough-cut on
mute just to the visual and during that
period of around five months all the
dialogues were on the translation and we
got the authority files and we put them
we were just blown away of some of the
some of the dialogues which are the
first version of the rocket that like
the scene with maybe most of the people
doesn't sit
like the dialogue is there will be
spring which is it thank you thank you
but not knowing the language was
actually the best thing that happened
for this film because it brought the
strong visual side of it because when
you don't understand the language you
try to focus on everything else that you
see on the body language on the
situation so it helped us to see the
film as the audience would I think it's
why it's translated to so many countries
because you watch this movie and it just
visually you're taking in instantly and
you're taking in by the face as you're
taking in by the characters it's such a
beautiful work I'm gonna talk briefly
about casting I mean there's amazing
performances and all the films Pedro you
you did when you were when you when you
start a cast need you always have
Antonio in mind you worked with a lot of
years regular spat company in this
picture not usually when I'm when I'm
writing around visualize the faces her
because as this as the story changed a
lot of you in the development so I
prefer not to have a face or reference
the only movie that I am that I remember
that I wrote thinking about Antonio in
in my mind it was tie me up tie me down
but but I made a bluebies with him so in
this case I know and I just when I have
the word I finish the script of course
Antonio was the first name that appears
in my mind just for a question of a
personal mental mental sanity I put two
names under Antonio just in case it
wasn't like a script but you know I mean
I means that I hesitate hesitated but I
was I mean I was like I I sent in the
squid but I thought that I need a
conversation with him because what I
wanted
him for this specific story it was just
the opposite of what we were doing in
the eighties and after in with the skin
on living so it was almost I mean I
listen in one interview that Antonio
said Pedro what could the months from me
it was just to kill Antonio Banderas and
this is what I did I mean listen and it
is a good explanation I I never I never
dared to ask him that
but I want something completely
different on on his way of acting on
that I mean that tones that Antonio was
famous because he was very good in that
one that it was the opposite of that so
and and I thought that it was a very
hard work because it does the is not the
nature of Antonio Antonio saw a rock
person and passionate and that was
perfect for the characters that I wrote
in the eighties I crazy people but in
this case have an isolated and painful
land on the enormous depressed so I I I
was I mean I was not sure I was a tirana
would happen just to to get that
performance and I think you know I mean
at the end I was completely but I mean
more than surprised that he was it was
the easier work with him and and I even
ask myself now why it was so easy for
him to make this this corrected that it
was the opposite of everything he did in
the past and I think one of the reason
perhaps that of course there will be
more and the talented is included always
his talent he was he has heart condition
I mean three years before two years
before did we shoot the movie and around
his Bethesda California he had three
heart operations in that role meant a
pure fear layer lay entry bonier on the
Khmers la factorio
the last mafia news so
actually interventions in what you might
call the factory of emotions e para me
era era muy impression on t ver que como
la cienaga
Arliss mafias porque Nabisco Bukharian
our Desdemona era sin embargo era el
modo perfecto para bellum and so I was
quite surprised to watch him react to
emotions in ways in which I had never
seen him done before and that
nevertheless it was perfect for this
particular film yo creo que de Mar de su
trabajo y del mio marito este momento
por el corazon creo que fueron feein
para que era interfering a MEP element a
mystery mafia very low and really beyond
sort of my work as a director or his
work as an actor I think this condition
with his heart really sort of led him to
give me a performance that really sort
of gave me shivers to watch him your
cast is extraordinary and there's so
many people there's you know I I don't
know that much about how you cast the
film but it feels like you've got
professional actors you got children
you've got non pros it's this great
collage and everyone feels so real so
how did how did you cast this film a
certain party Machado de travail of
exceed hopefully six only professional
communication tool to the personage
conveyed on film see a person cannot
cast I don't concede on Terry Thomas it
important Ave Ave Corpus Christi of
Casilla astrology visual is applique
institution Mercedes
morose model cinnamon same mark in the
amount of diversity image etc no Tito
the fairy Meridian we're dead Canseco
remember from Co Africa Myanmar provide
a little competition official I can open
wide
was a scanner one table I don't wanna
say the contributor yes for me was well
it was important to work with the first
the three cups are professional actors
they've been in several movies before
all the other ones are actually non
actors and it was really important for
me to work with them because I wanted to
involve them and and and have them stand
out and have new faces also stand out
and just emerge because French cinema is
clearly not very diverse I am the first
French African or let's let's just be
more direct the first black person
French black person to be to win I
cannon to be at the Oscars and so I
wanted to
[Applause]
my film to reflect diversity and honey
land you don't it's not traditional
casting but how did you find her and
that's really you know how did you you
cast a movie that way how did how did
this person come into your life I think
she as if you ask her she would say she
casted us she likes to say that she's
the one who found us and basically she's
somebody who really really wants to tell
her story and that was the easy part in
the process but before we reach her we
did a like a lot of months of research
especially because we didn't plan this
obviously from the beginning not we
didn't have the topic especially not the
bees
like we just went in the area with a
task to make a short documentary about
nature conservation in this area and
from there we just had to do a complete
research about everything the only thing
we knew is that we want to find a really
strong character so we didn't stop
before we actually find it solidified
for you we're like you were you guys
were following her and you're like this
is this is the one this is our stars
clear you're good at casting yawn you
you had a very I heard you had a very
interesting audition process for your
leading role your lead is amazing but
you you basically had actors come in and
do two sets of something yes well that's
usually I work like this I I I would
like to give actress as much space as
possible in front of the camera to know
who am I talking to who am i watching
so around 300 male actors actors games
came to
for the edition and they had two tasks
one was because we were looking for
somebody who would contain a fake crease
and a hoodlum character right so two
tags
two tasks one was to perform sermon in
front of the camera and sing in their
own words and the other one was to I
asked them to express anger towards the
camera as if as if the camera was their
friend who turned who had turned them in
at the police station
so this streetwise character and funny
enough every every film is an adventure
right so funny enough health it was half
in health half of the slide was great
and in being priests and health and
being the streetwise character and then
bartosh came and Partridge was already
pretty well-known and especially among
among dear viewers goers he was
performing on stage for many many years
he wasn't cast and films and may in
leading roles mainly he had obviously
experience with it but because of his
looks were are very characteristic he
was basically mmm usually playing
villains cuckoos psychos so he came I
didn't knew him before
he came and cuckoos I like the cookie
actually and he was meant to perform two
situations right and he was the only
person who wasn't good at neither by
saying good I mean because he understood
that it's not about it like this film
and thanks to him I realized that this
character is not somebody who is great
at being a priest or a hoodlum yeah he's
not a con man that's so interesting you
bring that he is somebody else he just
he just words rolls like a robe he
becomes a fake priest but he's also a
fake villain at the same time so thanks
to him I realized that and he realized
that before me intuitively so that's why
he's in the film amazing
and bong your your big task was to
create two families you had to create
two separate families that you believe
those people all live together how do
you how do you I'm casting the two
families actually three families
including the couple in the basement and
so it's a family so at the clinic I
catch from Pune Giga I care
Yoochun joking DNA put on unique you got
high mighty qu yang sang together so
it's not only about the DNA or the look
of it but they have to sort of have a
sort of share the atmosphere or
sensibility because their family so
composing assembling the ensemble
together was a big task and they did see
Jacqueline could oppose you colonel ng
caputo about you addressed addressed
earlier could a job much Amagi intake so
I started with the father and son
character of the poor family mr. mr. Kim
and his son and then I built up the
ensemble and the very last piece of the
puzzle was the guy in the bunker
contacted and painted a legends are
important human independent my eye so
could be able to attach any cell so I
wanted to work with the actor was
relatively unknown to the audience to
the regular people and I saw him in one
of the independent movies they could
your current did Sanjay sir check a
spoiler on a combo tension between your
cardio I told them put that chip okay
catch a spoiler so woody Cooper not sure
so she kept on right there so
unfortunately because his existing
itself is sort of like a spoiler so if
we are to introduce himself like this
guy is supposed to be living in the
bunker of this rich guy house that
itself is a spoiler so whenever we went
to the festival including can we would
sort of hide in
yeah it was it was very sad that during
the premiere screening of in can he
stayed in the very dark corner of the
second floor apart from us and he ran
away just before that he ran away and he
was hiding so man and but now he's fine
so he will come to the Oscar ceremony
yeah one last really quick question for
all of you
what's what's great about this category
is your nominated your film is nominated
but your country is actually nominated
and I'm wondering what what's the
reaction been back home for each each of
you and what's been the reaction back in
France baila Java in Part C in gone
movin gran partita contrary to Sharon's
horizontal consensus like her in Part II
don't extend what normal a second summer
to can only try shared or present
elephants in super macho
yes the large majority of a large
majority of people in France are very
very happy and pleased with it now
there's a clearly a very small small
minority of right people not too happy
with this nevertheless we're really
really pleased and proud to represent
friends here and North Macedonia how how
are they feeling about here your movie
so in a small country but this is
actually third nomination third and
fourth I don't know it's total mess
there we are not more than a month we
are not there here we turn off our
Facebook's today actually Macedonia in
majority they didn't even know what's
documentary before not even films maybe
and now you're probably the most
educated country in documentaries every
village even the one without electricity
people know about there are several
states in the United States that don't
know about documentaries they don't take
a personal actually I lied I do have one
extra question for you guys did you get
stung I was watching this movie tarah51
just once or twice that's amazing and
also we got a national threat that if a
teacher doesn't come to the Oscars we
should send our best person to she's
here tonight but she's very little
summary she signed with Gersh
but it's true that she got a house she
got a new house right
oh wow good how about Poland that what's
been the reaction Oh back in Poland
people are very proud they root for us
we were like this Corpus Christi team so
we're very happy to be representing
Poland this year last year it was
a few viewers before it was in darkness
by ignition coholan so it was Agnieszka
horrible públicos key this year us which
we're super happy to be here and I have
to say knowing this is the last question
that I am extremely proud and I so
appreciate being with you guys it's
[Applause]
South Korea very first time nomination
yes
[Applause]
actually two Korean short animation was
nominated before and dc-dc also we have
another great documentary short
documentary called in the absence which
is so great but maybe parasite is very
first nomination of such a movie country
you guys love the Korean films there's
so much Korean film you portion even in
Los Angeles see a lot of Korean cinema
even nomination Ju no more parasite
opener that had an angle know what could
we do to access okay good my studies
come on Deponia Kurosawa mo0 night I'm
very certain watch our own cotton book
Oslo latter was a settlement happily so
my wishes parasite would open up for all
of you to look into the Korean cinemas
as well and just like typical Japanese
has a deep deep history of Kurosawa and
yes oshiro we also have a great
filmmakers so I hope that parasite opens
up for all of you to look into Korean
cinema just yeah just just googling the
Korean Film Archive calm you can find
out that there is great streaming mobile
Korean classics yeah and Pedro Spain how
are they been reacting well you know his
pain is very proud that we will reach
just the nomination but are also genome
I feel very in a very different way when
I am selected before by my country like
this and then we talk to her that I was
not I felt much more free at the moment
and now I have a kind of responsibility
that if I didn't advise if I if we don't
get this nomination I couldn't go back
to a Spain
it was I mean I need it I mean I was
begging for this domination anyway I so
that's enough
I mean this is I mean this is the I mean
the word we I have to do and he's done
already by the way I I got a feeling
that I'm not going to be the winner on
Sunday under but III would like to tell
to my fellows just he case and that that
I wanted to not not only to sure to
dedicate the award that perhaps are not
going to receive damn and I want to
dedicate it to all of them i I I'm
feeling like in the best company and
with these guys and I feel very very
proud to be part of his life
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the nominees for
best international feature film and
thank you so much the translators you
did an amazing job really appreciate it
thank you all thank you all very much
for coming